royal caribbean is the first cruise line
to get cdc approval to sail in u.s
waters
after more than a year of being shut
down the first ship will leave from
florida next month with
only fully vaccinated adult passengers
and crew
even though that state has banned
vaccine passports as
elizabeth palmer reports other cruise
ships they're on the move in europe
when the iona sailed into southampton
two weeks ago
she made quite the splash thousand
passengers will board
later this summer for her maiden cruise
to scotland
with captain wesley dunlop in command
how lucky am i to be at the helm for it
i cannot
wait challenging that optimism
are the floating nightmares from last
spring
remember the zen dam turned away from
country after country with a deadly
covet outbreak on board
or the two and a half thousand people
who spent their dream vacation
in quarantine on the diamond princess in
japan
simon calder is a travel writer it's a
huge
pr challenge the people who are most
susceptible to
kovid 19 older travelers
are the absolute prime demographic for
the cruise
industry the industry is trying to build
confidence aboard one of the first
british cruises of the season
last week calder not only had to have a
covid test
but everyone on board had to be fully
vaccinated
and that's going to be the new normal
everywhere so we've listened to our
guests and they overwhelmingly told us
that they wanted to travel with fellow
vaccinated travelers
the pandemic has cost the cruise
industry 77
billion dollars globally and more than a
hundred and sixty thousand jobs
in just the united states a relaunch
is underway but it's going to be slow
with all those horror stories of
covid on the high seas at the start of
the pandemic still
fresh in public imagination you'd think
that the appetite for cruising would be
down
well think again all fine
waiting to go home elaine spencer was
one of the passengers trapped in
quarantine on the diamond princess in
fact
she's written a book about it so when i
wrote the book
i we both said that we're not sure if
we're going to go on a cruise
ever again ever again but a year
is a long time on dry land and over the
past few months
elaine and her husband have changed
their minds
their next cruise is already booked
there are some people who would say
you're
nuts yeah yeah and i think my kids think
we're nuts as well
loyalty like that will keep the industry
afloat
their research shows that two out of
three past
customers are ready for their next trip
for cbs this morning i'm elizabeth
palmer in southampton
england that's a very big boat
yeah i want a captain like that one who
said i cannot wait you want a captain
who's very enthusiastic he was
enthusiastic cruising works for big
families and you've got different ages
people that have different interests
you're all there together some people
don't like that but i think
i think it offers great options for
people looking for something to do
those things are like they're like
little cities yeah lots to do
very cool